for our series world of worship we sent
correspondents around the globe to show
us how different people celebrate their
faith and honor religious traditions
well this morning we head to the Middle
East in recent years Iraq has suffered
terrible violence often inflamed by
religious differences but in a country
where worship can come out of heavy cost
Charlie d'Agata discovered an unlikely
oasis hidden in the mountains
an ancient Christian monastery with each
twist and turn of the mountain road we
climb away from the reality of this
war-ravaged region and into the past to
a place of worship founded almost 1,400
years ago the robe on hormuz monastery
carved into and out of the very rock on
which it rests this ancient temple to
Christianity one of the oldest of its
kind in the world
overlooks the vast plains of northern
Iraq
its namesake Rabanne Hormuz traveled
these lands from Persia he lived as a
hermit for almost thirty years living an
austere life of isolation in the network
of caves that pushed deep into the
mountainside over time more monks made
the pilgrimage settling to in its
labyrinth the cave dwelling monks are
now long gone but we did bump into some
Iraqi history students breathing new
life into this ancient stone like 21
year-old Miriam Saleh geonji Christians
are an important part of the community
here in Iraqi Kurdistan she said they've
been here for thousands of years over
the centuries this place has been more
than a house of worship it's been a
sanctuary a safe place in a region
that's had more than its fair share of
upheaval the Mongols the Kurds the
Ottomans the Turks all over an this
territory at one point or another yet it
somehow survived but the biggest threat
came in modern times
when Isis rampage throughout this region
in 2014 the Islamic extremists targeted
anything to do with Christianity
churches that stood for centuries ruined
in a matter of seconds when Isis overran
nearby Mosel tens of thousands of
terrified Christians fled escaping to
Christian towns in this region until
Isis got so close they evacuated from
here too at one point the terrorist
group was just a 10-minute Drive away
from the Christian town of al-kahf that
sits at the base of the mountain
mercifully they never made it any closer
but the threat is still felt today here
praying to your God means planning for
the worst that armed bodyguard follows
the priests everywhere such a something
the monasteries head monk father den ha
Toma knows all too well he was in the
nearby city of Mosul
when Isis suddenly invaded five years
ago what do you think Isis would have
done if they reached this place when
Michael Sonny wherever they saw a cross
they smashed it he said I thought it
would be erased any traces of
Christianity huh da man even the Virgin
Mary there used to be a statue of her
they chopped the head off and left the
rest of the statue standing there if
they had reached here he said they would
have certainly destroyed this monastery
[Applause]
before the us-led invasion the
insurgency and Isis around one and a
half million Christians in Iraq there
are now barely 250,000 in fact there are
now more Chaldean Catholics the most
followed denomination among Iraqi
Christians in the United States than in
Iraq
[Music]
the regional archbishop recently
described Christianity in Iraq is being
perilously close to extinction which
means one of the oldest continuous
Christian communities in existence now
remains on a cliff edge for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata al kasha
northern Iraq